non
la propagande raciste la xénophobie et
l'antisémitisme sur l'internet autant de
thèmes qui prolifèrent dangereusement
sur la toile et justement pour endiguer
ce phénomène loes de l'organisation pour
la sécurité et la coopération en europe
tient en ce moment même une conférence
my ali saleh en bourse
un avion qui s'écrase sur le minaret
d'une mosquée cette vidéo américaine est
visible sur internet un journal où le
présentateur tient des propos clairement
racistes et antisémites
ce genre de messages appelant à la haine
raciale ou au terrorisme et largement
diffusées sur le net de plus en plus de
sites apparaître chaque année estimé à
quelques centaines il ya dix ans ils
sont plusieurs milliers aujourd'hui
en france une association de
prestataires de services internet a pris
l'initiative de lutter contre les
contenus incitant à la haine des sites
qu'il héberge en début de semaine ils
ont signé une charte où ils s'engagent à
signaler tout site illégal ce
prestataire héberge plus de 700000 site
cinq personnes sont chargées de les
surveiller en permanence selon
différents critères peut être le nom de
fréquentation du site si bascou une
fréquentation beaucoup plus élevé ça
peut être significatif de l'ong licite
et parfois très évocateur aussi un
espace disque occupé par le système
beaucoup de photos beaucoup de vidéo sur
la page d'accueil un lien est également
mis à la disposition de l'internaute
afin de signaler tous sites suspects si
nous paraît évident qu'il s'agit d'un
site illégal
le site est bloqué et ensuite nous
faisons un signalement aux autorités
judiciaires
systématiquement
comment inciter les pays du monde entier
à la même vigilance
c'est la question de cette conférence
internationale qui se tient actuellement
à paris
où une combinaison de levier le levier
juridique à travers les états
l'intervention des fournisseurs d'accès
la vigilance des individus etc si tous
les éléments de la chaîne de
responsabilités se mobilisent alors là
on peut avoir une action efficace sur
4000 sites incitant à la haine qui ont
été recensés l'an dernier
2500 sont hébergés aux états unis